conducting is slow there's a point where
the heat is vibrating the molecules
faster than the molecules can
communicate that fact so the solution to
this is Blobs of water Rise Up from the
bottom the hot water rises physically
move that can't happen in your iron pan
because it's solid the iron can only
move heat through conduction but the
moment the heat becomes s significant
whole pockets of water will rise up
replaced with cool pockets of water that
were above that come in below if I Rise
Up something's got to take its place if
you want to test this next time put in a
few raisins at the bottom sounds like an
awful
dish so you'll see the raisin Bob up and
down inside the liquid o and it's doing
that because it's following it's
following the pockets of water there you
[Music]
go